[Music]
[Applause]
chris mannix senior nba writer for
sports illustrated he was there in the
garden last night joins us on the
program when did you realize the game
was over last night
first quarter
first quarter i um
yeah i expected the celtics to come out
with a lot of energy in this game and
they did
but how the warriors responded in that
first quarter told me everything about
this game they were down 12 points at
one point in the first the crowd was
into it and then over like a three
minute stretch the warriors erased that
lead
and went into the second quarter with a
five-point lead that they would never
surrender so
i i knew then that you know they had
taken the celtics best punch they had
punched back steph curry was playing
great i just
you just knew right then and there this
was going to be a tough night for boston
well i wondered the celtics didn't play
well but how much of a role did the
warriors play in the celtics not playing
well at home
they played a big role because
defensively
golden state's not as good as boston
but they are
tighter defensively than boston if that
makes any sense like they
they don't make a lot of mistakes out
there defensively they're disciplined on
that end they make their rotations right
every single time and boston
just couldn't find a way to break
through especially jason tatum who was
you know had what his worst game i think
or one of his worst games of this series
in game six uh they just weren't able to
to break that defense because golden
state
doesn't make mistakes now the celtics
make a lot of mistakes and they did all
series long i said going into game six
dan the celtics would win as long as
they didn't turn the ball over at a
crazy level what did they do
turn the ball over at a crazy level 23
total turnovers
in this game for boss that was a serious
high for them and they're just they're
throwing the ball all over the gym
they're dribbling into traffic they're
committing offensive fouls it just
you know golden state beat them but by
some measure boston beat itself with the
way it played offensively the perception
of jason tatum today is what
uh
you know i i think if jason tatum had
played
in this series as he played in previous
series
we would be talking definitively as
of jason tatum as like a top five guy
like we would be looking at him as the
heir
to kevin durant now
because he looked overwhelmed by the
moment and because he couldn't unlock
andrew wiggins and that warriors defense
you're saying all right he's still a cut
below
those top tier guys i mean this was the
best season
of tatum's career all nba first team top
six in mvp balloting but
after watching these finals
you know he's got a ways to go or at
least a little ways to go before he
cracks into that top five six players in
the nba yeah he needs to develop his
game he needs to make better decisions
he needs to not settle for threes
uh you know watching jordan and kobe
develop a post game
you know i think that would be really
beneficial for him i know we keep saying
he's only 24. but he's got a lot of any
nba experience for somebody who's only
24. the perception of steph curry today
is what
i think you have to look at steph curry
as a top 10 player all time um and i
think that's because of the outcome of
this series uh andre goodale said
something at
the press conference last night that was
kind of a throwaway line in the moment
he called steph the best point guard of
all time
um
and that as you think about it in
hindsight like all right you're saying
steps better than magic but then
you kind of sort of stack them up and
you can make a legitimate argument but
he's not a point guard
he's a point guard no he's not he's
different he's a different point guard
no he's a points guard he's magic's a
point guard steps a points guard he
scores all right so
okay so does luca is more of a point
guard than steph is
i don't know
i don't know what the assist numbers are
like look he plays the position like he
is their starting point guard like that
and he's been their starting point
lebron is a better point guard lebron's
play with point guards like the bronze
he's played with point guards many times
it's great won a championship with kyrie
irving as his point guard
kyrie wasn't his point guard kyrie was a
shooter
no he was okay but he okay all right
well look
history's going to record steph curry as
a point guard it's going to say steph
curry point guard magic johnson point
guard is steph curry better than magic
johnson i don't answer that question but
i think after this series he can make a
reasonable argument for that he can make
a reasonable argument to be called top
ten
of all time looked in okay but who are
you taking out of the top ten
like we we we tend to cram in fifteen
into the two i agree i agree i i don't i
don't have my list in front of me i just
i i i think there's there's now a strong
debate pauline
give us the top ten and all right here's
a quick consensus michael jordan lebron
james kareem abdul-jabbar magic johnson
wilt chamberlain bill russell larry bird
larry bird tim duncan oscar robertson
kobe bryant you got shaq shaq and then
we're on to guys like durant elijahuan
julius irving okay who's coming out i
think you could i think at some point
you can have the tim duncan kobe oscar
robertson conversation with steph curry
being in that mix
you think steph is better than kobe
better i don't know better is the right
way to put but he's got he's more he's
as accomplished at this point he's got
four championships now on his resume
like
he's done it like he's been successful
he's a two-time mvp and
this series was won because of him like
he had 34 points in game four with the
warriors if they'd lost they'd be done
last night going into the fourth quarter
uh celtics made a run there at the end
of the third they were within 10 points
within the third steph curry went out
had 13 points in the fourth quarter to
seal that game so like he's he's doing
all the things people questioned that he
could do put a team on his back be the
lead player on uh on a championship
level team like he's doing it so yeah
like the three guys you mentioned the
back then duncan kobe oscar robertson i
would now say steph curry belongs in
that conversation at the very least okay
you're not getting an argument from me i
think i'm getting a strong argument from
you dan i'm getting i'm getting strong
no no it's strong strong vibes you're
getting but
um
how what's the window for golden state
to continue this
it's honestly like
i i was talking about this with somebody
last night it could be like seven years
if if you look at
what they have on that roster they've
basically got the oklahoma city thunder
on the back of that bench like you've
got two teenagers who were lottery picks
in moses moody and jonathan kaminga you
get jonathan uh james wiseman who hasn't
played in a year like these are all
these those three players would make up
the core of a rebuilding team a
rebuilding team that would be thrilled
to have all three of them i think steph
curry is going to age really well he's
shown that the last couple of years i
think clay thompson comes back next year
a better version of himself than he was
this year and draymond's still going to
be draymond he's not going to be
um
a great three-point shooter though he
shot the ball well last night but he's
going to be able to be a high level glue
guy defensive player for years to come
and as they regress slowly
theoretically these young guys who have
loads of talent are going to progress to
the point where next year you can
certainly say kamenga who played well in
spurts during the regular season could
be ready for a meaningful role andrew
wiggins is just 27 years old like he
just turned 27 in february why are you
yelling at me why are you yelling
i don't know you got me going early in
the morning with this whole oh he's not
a point guard oh he's not top 10. like
he kind of got me going there a little
bit with that so i plus your celtics
lost and that hurts i don't care i'm not
on a plane to san francisco right now
dan that's what matters okay that's the
most important thing in this
conversation but to the point kaminga
moody wiseman if they develop next year
if wise we can get back on the court
this window is like five plus years
because those guys theoretically should
be that good to be able to supplement
that roster
keep your head up
heads all the way up then until it goes
down all right uh the off-season story
to keep an eye on number one off-season
story is what
i would call it a co number one for me
it's bradley beal does he re-sign with
washington is there a sign-in trade
scenario in the mix there and damian
lillard what happens in portland if they
strike out in free agency uh i can't
imagine
lilla's gonna be all that happy about
coming back those are two guys that can
kind of change if they're traded
can change the dynamic of the league by
going into next season you know golden
state probably going to be right back
there again you see the hierarchy in the
western conference in the east boston i
don't think the celtics need many
changes to that team they go eight nine
deep with really good guys and the
experience they got from this finals
appearance is going to benefit them for
next year but lillard beal if they get
moved they can really shake up the the
power rankings in from either conference
and zion that extension
is that going to happen
yeah it just seems from and i haven't
checked in in a couple of weeks now but
it just seems like
the only question there is going to be
what kind of protections zion is okay
with um you know you remember the joel
embiid contract he signed a deal with a
lot of protections after that uh first
rookie deal expired i will i would
imagine and i believe this to be true
that new orleans is going to structure a
max level extension similar to what joel
mb got as long as zion is okay with it i
think he will be because he's going to
want to protect himself with guaranteed
money for the foreseeable future i think
a deal with zion gets done in new
orleans
steph curry is not a point guard
okay well what is he you want to
reclassify i i did i just told you he's
a point guard
okay but that's not something that is on
the official nba register a points guard
it's not forward center guard points
guard no no no no no
no no no we don't have positions it's
positionless the commissioner has
already said it's positionless
okay so when did point guard stop like
when did that stop being a thing like
after john stockton retired pretty much
okay so pretty much nobody's a point
guard is chris paul a point guard
yeah yeah yeah he's
continuing
yeah
yeah toronto put them in the same cover
christmas chris paul is a dinosaur he's
he's uh he's a throwback player yes
okay is lamelo ball a point guard does
it continue with him
um i would say he's close to being a
point guard
i don't know if he wants to be a point
guard and lonzo is more of a point guard
but but there there's not
you can't be the a point guard and you
don't even lead your team an assist
okay but magic was different than bob
cousy steph curry is different than
magic like
players evolve over time the game
changes you know i mean if you're known
for your passing more than your shooting
then you're a point guard
with the definition of a point guard
like a power forward okay i don't know
you have to be a certain size i know
what it was okay but do you have to be a
certain size to be a power forward
no well used to okay exactly you did but
that's same with the game changes like i
don't think positions change the game
change like
what's a center now a center is now your
point guard at least in denver it is
yeah like it
the game changes these players evolve i
i don't think you should change the
definition of the position because the
player changes in the game changes i
think you're still that's who you are
joel embiid's still a center steph
curry's still a point guard
no
they're just basketball players that's
all
don't have labels on people
i
try i try not to label people don't
label
thank you chris
you got it damn christmas
i don't know what we accomplished there
but he got all riled up he's short on
sleep his celtics lost